please meet Jane she has a high-risk
pregnancy but in 24 weeks she's on bed
rest at the hospital being monitored for
her preterm contractions she doesn't
look the happiest that's in part because
it requires technicians and experts to
apply these clunky belts on her to
monitor her uterine contractions
another reason Jane it's not so happy is
because she's worried in particular
she's worried about what happens after
her 10-day stay on bed rest at the
hospital what happens when she's home if
she were to give birth this early it
would be devastating as an
african-american woman she's twice as
likely to have a premature birth or to
have a still birth so Jane basically has
one of two options stay at the hospital
on bed rest a prisoner to the technology
until she gives birth and then spend the
rest of her life paying for the bill or
at home after her 10-day stay and hope
for the best
neither of these two options seems
appealing as I began to think about
stories like this and hear about stories
like this I began to ask myself is there
an alternative is there a way that we
could have the benefits of high fidelity
monitoring that we get their trusted
partners in the hospital while someone
is at home living their daily life with
that in mind I encourage people my
research group to partner with some
clever material scientists and all of us
came together in brainstormed and after
a long process we came up with a vision
an idea of a wearable system that
perhaps you could wear like a piece of
jewelry or you could apply to yourself
like a band-aid and after many trials
and tribulations in years of endeavors
we were able to come up with this
flexible electronic patch that was
manufactured using the same process
that they use to build computer chips
except the electronics are transferred
from a semiconductor wafer onto a
flexible material that can interface
with the human body
these systems are about the thickness of
a human hair they can measure the types
of information that we want things such
as bodily movement bodily temperature
electrical rhythms of the body and so
forth
we can also engineer these systems so
that they can integrate energy sources
and can have wireless transmission
capabilities so as we began to build
these types of systems we began to test
them on ourselves in our research group
but in addition we began to reach out to
some of our clinical partners in San
Diego and to test these on different
patients in different clinical
conditions including moms-to-be like
Jane here is a picture of a pregnant
woman in labor at our university
hospital being monitored for her uterine
contractions with the conventional belts
in addition our flexible electronic
patches are there this picture
demonstrates waveforms pertaining to the
fetal heart rate or the red corresponds
to what was required with the
conventional belts in the blue
corresponds to our estimates using our
flexible electronic systems and our
algorithms at this moment we gave
ourselves a big mental high-five some of
the things that we had imagined were
beginning to come to fruition and we
were actually seeing this in a clinical
context but there was still a problem
the problem was the way that we
manufactured these systems was very
inefficient had low yield and was very
error-prone in addition as we talked to
some of the nurses in the hospital they
encouraged us to make sure that our
electronics worked with typical medical
adhesives that are used in a hospital
we had an epiphany and said wait a
minute rather than just making them work
with adhesives let's integrate them into
adhesives and that could solve our
manufacturing problem this
make sure that you see here is our
ability to embed these sensors inside of
a piece of scotch tape by simply peeling
it off of a wafer ongoing work in our
research group allows us to in addition
imbed integrated circuits into these
flexible adhesives to do things like
amplifying signals digitizing them
processing them and encoding for
wireless transmission all this
integrated into the same medical
adhesives that are used in the hospital
so when we reach this point we had some
other challenges from both in
engineering as well as a usability
perspective to make sure that we can
make it used practically in many digital
health discussions people believe in the
idea and embrace the idea that we can
simply digitize the data wirelessly
transmitted send it to the cloud and in
the cloud we can extract meaningful
information for interpretation and
indeed you can do all of that if you're
not worried about some of the energy
challenges think about Jane for a moment
she doesn't live in Palo Alto nor does
she live in Beverly Hills and what that
means is that we have to be mindful
about her data plan and how much it
would cost for her to be sending out a
continuous stream of data there's
another challenge that not everyone of
the medical profession is comfortable
talking about and that is that Jane does
not have the most trust in the medical
establishment
she people like her her ancestors have
not had the best experiences at the
hands of doctors and the hospital or
insurance companies that means that we
have to be mindful of questions of
privacy Jane might not feel that happy
about all that data being processed into
the cloud Jane cannot be fooled she
reads the news she knows that if the
federal government can be hacked
if the fortune 500 can be hacked so can
her doctor and so with that in mind we
had an epiphany
we cannot outsmart all the hackers in
the world but perhaps we can present
them a smaller target what if we could
actually rather than
those algorithms that do data
interpretation run in the cloud what if
we have those algorithms run on those
small integrated circuits embedded into
those adhesives and so when we integrate
these things together what this means is
that now we can think about the future
where someone like Jane can still go
about living her normal daily life she
can be monitored it can be done in a way
or she doesn't have to get another job
to pay her data plan and we can also
address some of her concerns about
privacy so at this point we're feeling
very good about ourselves we've
accomplished this we begun to address
some of these questions about privacy
and we feel like pretty much the chapter
is closed now everyone lived happily
ever after right well well not so fast
one of the things that we have to
remember as I mentioned earlier is that
Jane does not have the most trust in the
medical establishment we have to
remember that there are increasing and
widening health disparities and there's
a inequity in terms of proper care
management and so what that means is
that this simple picture of Jane and her
data even if her being comfortable being
wirelessly transmitted to the cloud
letting a doctor intervene if necessary
is not the whole story
so what we're beginning to do is to
think about ways to have trusted parties
serve as intermediaries between people
like Jane and our health care providers
for example we begun to partner with
churches and to think about nurses that
are church members that come from that
trusted community as patient advocates
and health coaches to people like Jane
another thing that we have going for us
is that insurance companies increasingly
are attracted to some of these ideas
they are increasingly realizing that
perhaps it's better to pay $1 now for a
wearable device and a health coach
rather than paying $10 later when that
baby is born prematurely ends up in the
neonatal intensive care unit one of the
most expensive parts of a hospital this
has been a long learning process for us
this this iterative process of breaking
through and attacking one problem and
not feeling totally comfortable and
identifying the next problem has helped
us go along this path of actually trying
to not only innovate with this
technology but make sure it can be used
for people who perhaps need it the most
another learning lesson that we've taken
from this process that is very humbling
is that as technology progresses and
advances at an accelerating rate we have
to remember that human beings are using
this technology and we have to be
mindful that these human beings they
have a face they have a name and a life
in the case of Jane hopefully to thank
you